[Music]
first let me talk about why design is so
important today so once in a while the
pace of change accelerates and the
disruptions caused a severe dose at the
top get the game wipe down we're talking
about talking about the dinosaurs I'm
sure many of us feel the same way too
these days right well a lot of our
technical knowledge and traditional
advantages have actually quickly become
obsolete due to rapid changes in
technology for example Hilton hotels if
you know took 93 years to actually build
out an inventory of 600,000 rooms right
anyone have a guess and how long a B&B
to do the same for years today when we
think innovation right what typically
comes to mind is digital technologies
where the story often here is that
companies that digital centric will be
able to see small growth opportunities
is this alone true I say with the
application of digital technologies all
that's only one aspect of innovation
success because the other critical part
is that it has to be humanly desirable
to last year
LinkedIn actually did a survey with
4,000 employees in Singapore and found
that human centered design was one of
the top three skills that they're
pursuing and trying to develop for their
CV company is also all looking for this
skill as well why because it's in an
innovation driven economy to
successfully innovate we actually need
three elements it needs to be
technically feasible business viable and
last but not least market and desirable
and good design happens when all three
of them come
so good design helped shape more
desirable products more desirable
services and more desirable experiences
[Music]
you